[Music]
the movie that to do list there's a
scene where you pleasure yourself yeah
how do you approach that kind of scene
that's got to be a strange thing to
shoot on camera how do I approach it
mentally just did you work with an elite
core of the masturbator yeah I'm just
curious that's that's an intense okay to
simulate on film
fair question well I read it on the page
and it said brandy masturbates and in my
head I envisioned a a nice scene where
you just see my hand slowly go out of
frame right the frame stops frame stop
and then the hand yeah then that's just
the left left us up to the imagination
that's right that's what I thought
that's what I thought I was going into
but then when I showed up the camera was
mounted on the ceiling I was in my
underwear and a Clinton t-shirt and
there were a bunch of old men smoking
movie somehow yeah those are guys
working on the crew there just weren't
random old men okay three guys they
weren't smoking but I my memory I
and then in front of all these guys
yeah that's 13 of America soon yeah I
don't know the question that I'm
answering and my answer is hmm I thought
I was doing one thing and then when I
showed up it was a whole different thing
there was a full body shot and I asked
the director sure what should I do and
she said masturbate like it says in the
script
what kind directorial note like it says
in the script you know the title of this
movie
[Applause]